un parcours de rééducation half actifs
oui ça existe
il s'agit de rééduquer son odorat
retrouver le goût et sa vie d'avant le
qu'ovide 19 une vie dans laquelle michel
pouvait sentir tous les parfums plus que
la douleur physique c'est la peur du
loup et de leurs acquis et chivu
tétanise c'est déroutant ce
déstabilisant c'est le goût de vivre le
goût de vin disparaît très vite faut
être vraiment très fin je trouve qu'il
faut être très fort surtout quand la
durée longue si vous vous lever le matin
me sentais pas l'air je sentais ni le
taux ni le froid d'ailleurs de l'air
ambiant
l'art n'a pas de goût
vos odeurs corporelles non plus vous ne
vous sentez pas vous ne sentez pas vos
enfants vous ne sentez pas vos animaux
vous sentez pas quand ça en train de
cramer au niveau de la cuisine c'est
l'odeur enfin ne vous alerte pas fait
cheminer pareil vous ne sentez rien
c'est
la vie d'une platitude vous avez plus
vos repères
les premiers symptômes se sont fait
ressentir en novembre dernier les
courbatures une grande fatigue et
subitement la perte de l'odorat et du
goût pendant un mois et demi
aujourd'hui environ 70% de son odorat
est revenu mais pour les 30% restants
l'odeur est furtive à la zone tout en
haut du nez il ya un petit os perforé
qui est traversée par le nerf de
l'odorat ce nerf de l'odorat c'est la
seul endroit dans tout l'organisme votre
cerveau il est au contact quasiment de
l'extérieur
quand on a un virus pour éviter que le
virus ne contamine le cerveau il y as
probablement par un mécanisme de
protection
une section d'une aire de l'odorat une
disparition de ce nerf et ensuite il
faut qu'il repousse
c'est comme ça qu'on peut expliquer
cette perte de l'odorat
chaque vendredi dans le service orl du
professeur michel quatre patients sont
accueillis pour débuter le parcours dure
éducation alpha qui vivent tous ont eu
de kovy depuis perdu l'odorat et le goût
à différents degrés michel à de fortes
attentes olfactives le parfum des
passants lui apparaît comme celui de
l'essence de térébenthine et pour de
nombreux aliments c'est une odeur de
beurre rance des troubles qui la
handicape au quotidien on a aussi
beaucoup de personnes qui décrivent lors
du processus de récupération des
distorsions dans les odeurs qu'il sente
ce qu'on appelle des parts au smi voir
des cas cosmi c'est à dire qu'ils sont
des mauvaises odeurs à la place des
bonnes odeurs donc dans notre parcours
coordonné on propose différents examens
que vous avez dû voir mais aussi une
consultation orl et une consultation
orthophonique pendant laquelle on va
proposer aux patients des exercices qui
vont leur permettre d'essayer de
rééduquer leur odorat et leur goût des
attentes classés en plusieurs catégories
anomalies quantitative qui vont de la
noce me où on ne sent rien à l'hyper aux
semis ou lançons trop les odeurs et il
ya les anomalies qualitative qui inclut
la part au smi le fait de confondre les
odeurs ou trouver une odeur que l'on
apprécié nauséabonde et la fente au smi
où l'on sent une odeur qui n'existe pas
de nombreux exercices réalisés à
l'hôpital et à la maison permet aussi de
retrouver le goût
totalement liées à l'odorat mais dans la
majorité des cas 90% des patients
retrouvent la totalité de leur odorat
dans un délai compris entre 3 mois et 1